[Music]
bruce is with us in fort myers florida
hi bruce what's up
hey dave hey george i appreciate what
you guys do god bless you guys both for
uh spreading the good news and uh
helping people out with their finances
uh my question today is uh
what are your thoughts dave or both your
gentleman's thoughts on taking a degree
for a resume to get a job in corporate
america because the context here is i've
been in the military five years
now i'm in the reserve
and have a couple buddies who've done so
and um it's not illegal but it's looked
at as unethical but there's a lot of
jobs out there that require degrees and
there's like a 30 000 separation from
you know certain jobs that require them
and don't require them
but um so what's unethical here
just the integrity of
pretty much lying on your resume i
suppose but the company does doesn't
even verify that you have a degree or
anything they just want to see it oh i
thought you said you were going to
really get a degree instead of just
saying you have one
well that's my plan but i wanted your
two cents on it because it's
it's uh not just a money thing of course
but like i mean there's a lot of career
opportunities and i know a lot of cfos
at these companies who don't have
degrees and they've made it by word of
mouth by relationships but
everything but a degree and it's like
is it worth it or
uh i mean i mean not is it worth it but
is it does it make sense to
if you're asking us if you should lie on
your resume the answer is no
uh if the answer if you're wanting to
know should you get a degree and
actually get one so that you can get a
job that pays 30 grand more that is a
discussion we can have but no i'm not
going to tell you to go lie about having
a bachelor's degree so you can go get a
job
even if it works i don't feel good about
that
right and that's the thing a lot i have
a couple friends who've done it and i
don't get better friends i don't care
about your crooked friends um you need
to be a man of
integrity right and that's i mean that's
what i assume
let me tell you what let me tell you i i
don't hire people here we've got 1157
people working on our team today
that's as of this morning
and um i don't hire people based on
having a degree
not a single person in here got hired
because they had a degree
they got hired because at some point in
the interviewing process we became
convinced that they could do the job we
were hiring them for now some of that
being convinced might be
that they have a degree but we have
executive directors of marketing who do
not have marketing degrees and we have
some that have a master's in marketing
both and both can do the job and they
both got the job because they can do the
job if however i was to discover with
any one of the team members that worked
here no matter how long they've worked
here that they had lied about having a
degree
to get the job i would fire them
instantaneously
not because of the degree but because
they're a liar and i don't want to work
with liars
right
that's fair and i i i i'm on your side
dave i just had to check in because i
know people have done it and again i
know you're not saying i know people
have done it too i had a lady that
worked here one time that told us she
had a master's degree and after she quit
she came back five years later she's a
friend and said i have felt guilty since
i've known you because i lied to you the
entire time i've known you and i have to
come clean and tell you i do not have a
degree a master's degree in marketing
and she worked here i don't know 25
years ago or something and i still know
her to this day and i still like her
but i would have fired her for lying
yeah
on that so bruce what's the harm in you
just going to get a degree if that's
what you want to do do you have to have
a degree to succeed in corporate america
no do you is a degree valuable some are
uh can you get in the door some places
without a degree yes
can you get into
getting it
uh do the door some places without a
degree no some places require a degree
for you to even have a conversation and
that isn't the place i want to work
anyway because they're more concerned
about pedigrees and degrees than they
are actually getting the frequent
freaking work done
right and to answer your question george
the context is kind of like i've been to
special forces for the marine corps and
i know some guys in the field teams and
like et cetera and so like that
experience is
way more than you can get any college
degree i agree
it's just different and it's a different
kind of experience and expertise so like
but dude if you ran if you ran a seal
team
you can project manage
right but
i guess my question is like it's there
like a lot of things in america are
backwards of course that's what's well
known but
requiring a degree seems just like such
a
bad filter to have here it's just
if the 100 filter is you must have a
degree between you and me i wouldn't
want to work there
you got it okay
do you know what you want to do
it would be sales some type of business
development but sales related
very few sales positions require a
degree
they require the ability to sell
the ability to make the ability to
handle your verbal skills and articulate
an idea craft a narrative create a
persuasive environment and show people
the need and fill the need this is sales
build value that is greater than the
amount of time and the amount of money
that the customer is going to put forth
and the customer will part with their
money every single time and that's sales
that's how it works he's got a free
degree from dave do you have a degree i
do in communication no one's ever asked
no one cares
but you trust me but you started here as
a lowly intern that's right
and work your way all the way up to the
email bag that's right
i wasn't marketing though for four years
and my degree helped i don't think it
was a factor in the conversation it was
a factor in that some of the things you
learned in getting the degree or you put
tools in your belt exactly and i've got
a business degree i don't have a
master's degree i do have a phd in d-umb
yep which is one less than john deloney
has
so there's something to be said
you're at least half as smart as john
no matter what your phd is
depending on what your job was in the
seal teams um
i've worked a lot with those guys a lot
with special forces guys and um
we we do a lot of stuff with the
military and i'm a tactical shooter i
enjoy hanging out with them and learning
from them on that stuff and so
you're more than qualified to step into
some of these roles if you can just get
the interview so hang on we're going to
send you ken coleman's two books
proximity principle and from paycheck to
purpose read those and you'll land the
job you do not have to have a degree to
go into sales
not when you've got military experience
with special forces you don't
and um
and you certainly want to continue to be
a man of honor and a man of integrity
because that's how you started your life
and you need to continue your life that
way that is how
most people prosper is from integrity
very few people with a lack of integrity
have a long-term
prosperity and that was part of the
millionaire study that we did as well
because there's integrity shows up all
the time yeah
and so i got to tell you that's why i i
there's
there's very few things on the planet i
hate
as much as taxes
i
hate
taxes i think they're unfair
i think the money is completely wasted
by washington i think it's a disaster
i'm politically philosophically
spiritually opposed to the unbelievable
level of taxation that our country puts
on us while still fifty percent of
americans pay zero in federal income tax
and they take my freaking head off with
taxes but i pay every
dime
i owe exactly not a penny more
but we calculate it precisely
because it has nothing to do with the
irs it has nothing to do with the stupid
congress it has nothing to do with the
stupid federal government it has to do
with my
integrity
and so we run a lot of cash through this
place and every
freaking dime of it is reported exactly
and you know so i get audited it'll be
no problem
no problem come on in uh
i don't cheat on my taxes and if i was
ever going to cheat on anything
by god it'd be the place to do it it
would be i would start right there if
i'm gonna be a cheater that'd be the
first line on the list right there buddy
you wouldn't add a degree on your resume
dave
that one don't even come up no because
i'm not pissed about that yeah i guess
you haven't had to do a job interview in
like ever
it's been a while yeah
yeah i'd love to see that though our hr
department interviewing you for the job
a ceo